welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
amber turd in your bed in this video
we're breaking down the stand
the second episode has just dropped and
similar to the first one we
predominantly follow two characters
and see how their arcs both reflect one
another this is of course similar to the
first episode
in which we saw things from the
perspective of harold and stew
stew was a kind-hearted man thrown in at
the deep end
who seemed like a genuinely nice guy a
bit
bit like myself juxtaposing this though
harold was a toxic and manipulative
stalker
that wished to appear as the sort of
stew archetype in order to win the
affections of franny
however she wasn't fooled and in the end
she fell for stew instead
which scorned harold massively the
similarities between the pair
are even hinted at in this entry when
stew is believed to be harold at one
point
i think going forward that most of the
episodes will follow two characters
this time we're in the shoes of singer
larry underwood and a criminal
named lloyd who becomes locked up in a
prison larry is a thief who stole his
friend's songs in order to become famous
but in the end he doesn't really receive
any comeuppance
he's seen as a rock star amongst his
peers and this is very much
muradin lloyd who is too actually
referred to one at one point in the
episode
this is because he's believed to have
killed a policeman but we learn that
isn't
actually the case and thus both are
pretending to be something that they're
not
in order to rise through the ranks of
the societies that they find themselves
in
now that's the premise and from here on
out we'll be discussing more in-depth
spoilers that include
elements of the book that may or may not
ruin certain things
i'm not going to be jumping too far
ahead in the plot but i will be going
over
certain tidbits in regards to nadine
that could give you a heads up on where
things will be going
that's your warning as i genuinely don't
want to spoil things
no matter what the channel is called
anyway similar to last week
the episode has a non-linear way of
telling the story
and we pick up with larry making his way
to the free zone in boulder after
receiving a message from mother abigail
one thing i forgot to mention last week
that adds to the duality aspect of the
series
is that abigail and randall flag both
juxtapose each other in several ways
the former is an old black woman whereas
flag appears to be a young white man
and before you can say get woke go broke
just bear in mind yet the book was
written about 42 years ago
now abigail's dreamscape takes place in
a field whilst flags is amongst a rocky
desert environment
thus we have this idea of one being with
nature
whilst the other is a harsh landscape
that is slowly being taken over by
symbolisms of sin
such as las vegas but it's a love a
lovely place though
now larry is joined by an autistic boy
named joe
and also a woman called nadine cross
though it's not really touched upon in
the episode
nadine is actually a virgin and that's
probably because
she poops in your bed i'm sorry i'll
stop oh she's
she's a virgin because every time
someone gets close to her
it's like some outside force sweeps in
and scares the person off
in the book nadine actually believes
that this is tied to some sacred dark
person
and that she must wait for him so that
he can be her first
joe also goes on a journey in the book
and we discover that he's actually
called leo
but due to his regress state he's never
spoken or told anyone his true name
the group arrive at boulder and meet
stew which shocks larry
as somehow he already knows his name we
discover that everyone who's ventured to
the area
has had a vision of abigail which has
drawn them to it and that she's reached
out to the survivors in order to pull
them together
jump to five months earlier and we join
larry who's about to perform on stage
minus his band because of captain trips
they've all become sick
but after seeing his mother he decides
to head out on stage
now this differs highly from the source
material as in that
larry was already massively successful
and here
he's sort of on the come-up because of
his chart-topping song
baby can you dig your man in the work he
had turned to a life of drugs
now though that's laced through this it
is slightly altered here
but it's something that you should be
aware of as his stardom was more
prominent in the source material
bit off topic but with the yeah we've
had in 2020
did anyone else find this gig scene a
bit i don't know it's
it's a bit close to home it's kind of
crazy looking back and seeing just how
accurate king's predictions were
especially with how ignorant everyone
was unless they have it
no one's paying attention to the disease
and larry is even caught snatching
stage drinks without anti-backing his
hands 50 times
because you know everyone's just living
wild and free his friend wayne stuckey
arrives but
unlike the original work he's clearly
got a grudge against the character
in the book wayne was actually someone
who tried to turn larry away from
descending into darkness
and he was portrayed as more of a good
guy
rather than someone who would hold a gun
to their friend over stealing a chorus
at the same time lloyd is being locked
up and we learned that he was part of a
botched arm robbery
in which his partner went crazy and
tried to get him to poker eyes as
shopkeeper
yeah king's king's dialogue doesn't
always work
now a policeman intervened and was
killed by his friend
and thus lloyd took the fall in the end
in the original work
lloyd was actually a mass murderer
whereas here he's clearly reluctant when
it comes to killing
similar to what we see in the source
material he teams up with randall
but due to the way that the series is
diverting from the work
i think he might also go on a different
tangent
anyway nadine meets franny and we get a
tour of the town
whilst they discuss the dream summoning
and the former agrees to take care of
joe as a maternal figure
cut to the dreamscape again and we see
randall trying to tempt larry by putting
his name up in lights with a las vegas
sign
he's awoken from this by memories of new
york namely the outbreak in which his
mother came down with captain trips
and thus died from it larry took her out
of the hospital
and she passed away in his home whilst
the rest of the world completely
collapsed around him
to make matters worse wayne also arrived
with a gun
however he too died and thus larry was
able to take his stash of drugs from the
trunk of his car
and party like it's the end of the world
now he does carry this with him
throughout most of the episode and we
don't actually learn what happens to it
so i'm guessing that further down the
line it will pop up again
it wasn't in the book so i can't really
say what's going to be going on with
it but yeah just something to bear in
mind as we go into the other episodes
he wakes up on a bench in central park
and finds the world a completely
different place
in which everyone is able to do what
they want
yes i will join you running naked at
yankee stadium
we can be the yankee wankies now we hear
gunfire far off in the distance
and i believe that this might be the
group we encounter later on
larry makes his way through the park and
it's at this point he comes across rita
blakemore
played by heather graham the bear
actually discussed a character known as
the monster shouter
and though he doesn't feature in this
entry he was present in the original
show and book
the monster shouter was a religious
homeless man that stood shouting
bring out your dead and the character
preached that doomsday was approaching
but here he doesn't even get a cameo he
was originally played by kareem
abdul-jabbar
and his corpse was found stabbed to
death in the streets but here he's
completely omitted
we do hear him shouting later on which
is followed by more shooting
so i'm guessing that he was killed by
the gang rip
now back in the present time larry's
taken to see abigail
and what's the sort of oracle from the
matrix meeting
he's not allowed to say what she told
him but i do think that this will of
course be revealed in this series
larry is also introduced to nick andross
who's a deaf mute that's blind in one
eye
intercut with this are larry's
nightmare's a flag and it's clear that
abigail knows he's sought out by the
villain
now in the past we watch as rita and
larry get it on and they decide to leave
new york
after it becomes clear that the city is
dangerous they're stumbled upon by a man
who offers larry a million dollars to
take rita off his hand
and hey not the worst deal that's been
offered this year
after turning it down more men arrive
with guns
and nurse larry and rita flee into the
sewers
in the original work they actually went
through the lincoln tunnel which was
filled with the dead
but in both the pair split up after rita
becomes overwhelmed by the environment
larry hallucinates his mother's body in
the sewage and sees rats crawling out of
her mouth
which is enough to give anyone
nightmares however he makes it through
and finds rita on the other side
which is where the pair finally leave
the city now one of the big mysteries
that surrounds this entry
is what actually happened to her as we
know from the flash forwards
she's not at the camp and we discover
that she actually ends her own life in
order to escape the hell that she's
found herself
in i don't know man the yankee wankies
wasn't that bad it should it should just
come with us anyway
in the tunnels i think she realized that
larry just had his own interests at
heart
i wouldn't stay with her and thus she
was truly alone
larry cared more about the stash than he
did her and he carried that through the
sewers instead of ditching it
in order to care for the character now
the show does hide her fate
so it is possible that she could return
down the line
but in the book it is actually revealed
that she died
in the work we discover that larry woke
up next to her dead body
and it was probably one of the most
shocking scenes in the piece
this of course mirrored his mother's
death and his hallucination
and i was actually surprised that they
didn't include this reveal of her
as i think it would have been a fitting
way to show how he was haunted by this
motif
again though you know they didn't show a
body so she could still be alive
but i guess we'll find out one way or
the other now at boulder we see as
nadine
joe and larry settle into their new digs
nadine stares out the window
and we get the feeling that flag has
been watching her they never meet but
she does get drawn towards a planchette
which is basically a ouija board that
you will likely use to reach out to him
elsewhere larry comes face to face with
harold and we see that he looks up to
him
because of the signs that he left larry
and harold do share some common ground
as both believe that a woman was taken
from them because of the circumstances
i think that the pair will become a lot
closer in the season
now i haven't been talking too much
about lloyd because
due to being trapped in a prison very
little actually happens to him
being locked in his cell whilst the
majority of people die around him
means that he has to resort to
cannibalism and eating rats in order to
survive
flag appears at the end and turns the
magical stone he's been carrying into a
key
with the initials rf on it so that he's
constantly indebted to him
flag could have freed him at any time
but instead he waited until he was at
his lowest
and had sunk into eating others so that
he had a powerful ally
in the original work lloyd is very much
flag's right hand man
and this character is the first one that
we've seen him recruit personally
this shows how important he is to the
villain and the episode ends with the
two going off together
with flags saying that he believes this
is the beginning of a beautiful
friendship
this of course references casablanca and
i
am bot of the yankee wankers so nice
little way to close out the worst video
i've ever
made now that wraps up the entry and
don't forget that on the 30th of
december we're giving away three copies
of the lord of the rings 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning it's like the video first
for whatever reason make sure you
subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the entry if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the first
episode which will be linked on screen
right now
we cover everything you need to know
about stu and harold so definitely check
it out after this
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video and if you're watching
this before christmas then i hope you
had a good one
i've been paul you've been the best i'll
see you next week
take care much love peace